[Music]
now let's turn to Foreign Affairs and
I'm delighted to be joined Again by John
mimer who is a professor of
international relations um and he is
based at the University of Chicago uh
and he's also been I think it's fair to
say John you've been quite controversial
this year uh I know you might disagree
with that label but you've been quite
controversial this year and last um in
your uh arguments on Ukraine Russia um
and now as we will talk about in a bit
on uh
Gaza um but let's start with the news uh
if we may about Ukraine because zilinsky
was in Washington uh last night um
pleading for a a $60 billion Aid package
which it looks as though is not going to
be forthcoming um but President Joe
Biden has reiterated his support for
Ukraine um are we at a stage now where
American support for the Ukraine is
starting to EB not just among some
Republicans as people always like to say
but among Democrats and the political
class I think there's no question about
that I I think that uh uh up until uh
the late summer uh most uh
of the foreign policy establishment most
people in the foreign policy
establishment in the United States
thought there was a good chance that
Ukraine could win the war actually
defeat the Russians inside of Ukraine I
think it's now clear that that's not the
case I think it's clear to almost
everybody that the balance of power has
shifted in a marked way in the Russians
favor and independent of this Aid
package uh the Russians are on the March
and there's all sorts of reasons to to
think that the ukrainians are going to
have a very difficult time stemming the
tide uh so I think this overall
pessimism independent of the aid package
uh has contributed to the pessimism here
in the United States and the
unwillingness of people to Fork out huge
amounts of money to Ukraine would you
then argue uh that uh essentially the
Western push to help Ukraine has been
futile I think there's no no question
I've argued for a long time that we are
leading Ukraine down the Primrose path
uh I think that pushing to bring Ukraine
into NATO was a huge mistake and uh
Putin made it clear when we announced in
April 2008 that we were going to pursue
that policy that he would destroy
Ukraine before he would let that happen
and in fact that is what happened is
happening uh Ukraine is already lost a
sub substantial portion of its territory
and I believe will lose more and it will
end up as a dysfunctional rum State uh
so this is a disaster for Ukraine I
believe if we hadn't pushed forward to
bring Ukraine into NATO that Ukraine
would probably be intact today there
would be no war and I even believe
Ukraine would still continue to uh
control Crimea but it the war hasn't
gone uh brilliantly for Vladimir Putin I
think that's fair to say um
uh you know it if there had been a peace
in February March
2022 uh do you think Putin would have
had a stronger hand then or a weaker
hand
then Putin did not want this war he went
to Great Lengths before February 24th
2022 uh when the war started to uh head
it off at the past he wanted to come up
with a diplomatic solution and then
shortly after the war broke out in
February uh he was negotiating with the
ukrainians uh to work out a deal uh and
at that point in time he was not talking
about uh incorporating any uh Ukrainian
territory uh safe for Crimea which had
already been anex uh into uh Russia and
all he really cared about it's quite
clear from all the reports of the people
who are involved in the discussions was
NATO expansion into Ukraine he wanted a
neutral Ukraine and if he had gotten a
neutral Ukraine this is right after the
war started I believe there's a good
chance the war could have been shut down
but it was the Americans and the British
who moved in and basically told zalinski
that he had to walk away from the
negotiations because we believed that we
could win the war we meaning Ukraine
plus the West uh and in
20122 it actually looked like that might
be the case but now it's quite clear
that 2023 has been a disastrous year for
the ukrainians and if anything the
Russians will win the war did you ever
think uh then you said it looked as
though Ukraine might be able to win the
war did you ever think or did you ever
say that you thought that Ukraine might
be able to win the war in
2022 no I didn't think that uh Ukraine
would ever win the war uh I think it was
just a question of when uh Putin decided
to mobilize Russia and get serious about
fighting the war the fact fact is that
he uh invaded Ukraine with a very small
force uh I argue that he had at the most
190,000 troops uh there are a number of
smart people who pay very careful
attention to what happened uh during The
Invasion who argued that he had at the
most a 100,000 troops but this was a
small military force and of course he
ran into real resistance or the Russians
ran into real resistance inside of
Ukraine uh because the Ukrainian Army
had been trained and armed by the West
this was a quite formidable fighting
force so the ukrainians styed the uh uh
the Russians but it was all a matter of
when the Russians would respond uh to
this stalemate uh that developed in the
summer of 2022 and mobilize uh many more
troops than Ukraine could mobilize and
in fact in late September uh the
Russians mobilized 300,000 troops and
then over the course of 2023 that's this
year uh roughly
420,000 men have joined uh the Russian
army so the Russian army is growing
bigger and bigger and at the same time
the Ukrainian Army is suffering enormous
casualties and it had a much smaller
Manpower pool to draw from to begin with
so in 2022 when the Russians hadn't
fully mobilized it looked like Ukraine
might win but
uh if you factored in mobilization on
the Russian side that was not a
realistic belief are you not um uh and
forgive me if this is impertinent are
you not um slightly underplaying uh the
extent of the Russian invasion at the
beginning of the war I mean they did
Menace Kiev um it did look very much as
though they were intending to take Kia
do you think that was just a
bluff I don't think they could have
taken KV if they wanted they just didn't
have enough troops Kiev is a city that
has roughly three million people uh you
know they had tens of thousands of
troops the Russians did uh in the Kiev
area there's no way they were going to
quickly take that it's quite clear that
what the Russians were interested in
doing or to put it more specifically
what Putin was interested in doing was
coercing the ukrainians into coming to
the negotiating table and cutting a deal
on Ukraine joining NATO he was not
interested in conquering Ukraine or
Conquering the rest of Ukraine as I like
to say it's the conventional wisdom in
the west that Putin was bent uh on
conquering all of Ukraine and making it
part of a greater Russia uh there is no
way that he could have done this with
190,000 troops if he was interested in
doing that again as I often point out
when the Germans invaded Poland on
September 1st
1939 they went in with you know more
than a million troops uh he would have
needed an army that was Far bigger uh
than the one that went into Ukraine in
February 2022 if he was bent on
Conquering the country and incorporating
into Russia uh and he was
not well uh let's move on to uh another
controversial subject that you've
written about this year um and that is
the war in Gaza uh and on your substack
uh you have a very uh powerfully written
piece called death and destruction in
Gaza um which says you want to be on the
right side of
History uh because you believe Israel is
p purposefully massacring a huge number
of
civilians um and you think uh
essentially it's a an attempted genocide
um almost uh that's quite strong
language is it
not I want to be clear I did not say
it's an attempt to genocide in fact I've
said publicly on a number of occasions I
do not believe that the Israelis are
pursuing a genocide here uh a very
prominent Israeli
born scholar of the
Holocaust uh has said that he believes
the Israelis have genocidal intent uh
and he makes it he's not arguing that
they're executing a genocide I do
believe that what the Israelis are doing
in terms of murdering huge numbers of
innocent civilians in Palestine or in
Gaza Palestinians in Gaza is a war crime
I think there's no question about that
uh and that's what I was criticizing the
Israelis for but I was not criticizing
them forci no you're quite right forgive
me for that I've misquoted you but uh I
mean one thing you do point to a lot in
your piece is the um very violent
statements of senior Israeli commanders
and they are quite shocking some of them
um but I mean I suppose the point is
they have just had a terrorist attack uh
and you know if you look back at 9/11
you know quite senior Americans said
some pretty shocking things in the days
after that uh are we not reading too
much into uh emotional
words I think if you look at the
language the uh is Israeli Elite is
using and we're not talking about a few
extremists in the population we're
talking about people in the cabinet
we're talking about active duty generals
retired generals if you look at the
language that they're using uh to
describe the Palestinians uh and to say
or describe what they want to do in Gaza
it's truly shocking uh and the this
language is what leads Omar bartov who
is the Holocaust scholar I was talking
about a minute ago to say that it looks
like there is genocidal intent on the
part of the Israelis and bartov by the
way is not the only person making this
argument other people other Scholars of
of the Holocaust and and of genocide are
making the same point and again I want
to be very clear here the argument is
not that the Israelis are executing a
genocide at this point in time that's
not the argument but there is clear
evidence that they're committing war
crimes by murdering huge numbers of
Palestinian civilians and doing other
things as well like starving the
population inside of Gaza but uh uh you
would not expect this from the Israelis
given the Holocaust given the horrors
that were inflicted on Jews in Europe uh
between
1939 and
1945 you would not expect Israeli
leaders to be talking about the
Palestinians in this way and talking
about doing to Gaza what some of the
leaders are talking about doing um I
suppose an obvious question is what else
do you expect Israel to do about Hamas
because uh they clearly they've had a
huge security failure um and uh Hamas is
an intractable problem for Israel and I
think neighboring Arab states
acknowledge that um that Hamas is a is a
a violent cult it is a terrorist
organization it is hellbent on uh
killing as many Israelis and Jews as
possible um how do we expect Israel to
deal with that
problem well there's no question that
Israel has the right uh to retaliate
against tamas it's completely
understandable that the Israelis are
bent on
eliminating uh Hamas uh in Gaza one can
understand that but there's a difference
between going after Hamas and punishing
on purpose the civilian population those
two different things if you go after
Hamas if you're the israelies and you go
after Hamas there is going to be a
significant amount of collateral damage
which is to say a lot of civilians are
going to be killed that's inevitable and
it's in large part because Hamas is
woven in in to the civilian population
but the Israelis are not simply going
after Hamas what the Israelis are doing
is they are purposely killing huge
numbers of civilians and the evidence
for this is overwhelming and the
evidence comes from inside Israel itself
if you look at the statements that
Israeli leaders are making and if you
look at the assessments of the bombing
campaign that are coming from inside
Israel and are well done assessments
it's quite clear that this is a classic
punishment campaign where the aim is to
kill large numbers of civilians and I
believe and there is a good amount of
evidence to support this that what the
Israelis are interested in doing in the
end is ethnically cleansing Gaza uh I
believe the Israelis would like to
ethnically cleanse Gaza and they would
like to ethnically cleanse the West Bank
they'd like to get rid of the
Palestinians uh from those two areas
very important to understand Freddy that
if you look at greater Israel which
includes Gaza the West Bank and what is
generally referred to as green line
Israel Israel before
1967 in those three areas that comprise
greater Israel there are approximately
7.3 million Jews and 7.3 million
Palestinians for Israel this is an
intolerable situation you certainly
can't have a democracy when you have
those kind of numbers because it soon
will cease to be Israel will soon cease
to be a Jewish state so what the
Israelis would like to do or many
Israelis would like to do certainly many
Israelis in the present government is
they'd like to ethnically cleanse Gaza
and they'd like to ethnically cleanse
the West Bank and there's all sorts of
evidence to support this uh so how do
you achieve that end one way to do it is
inflict massive punishment on the
civilian population to directly go after
the civilian population and that's what
the Israelis are doing that's not to
deny that they're not also going after
Hamas but this is not a military
operation that is specifically designed
to get Hamas and nothing
else Joe Biden has been uh quite clear
in his support of Israel and America um
generally tends to be very supportive of
Israel you of course wrote uh a famous
book The the Israel lobby with Steven
Walt um about the pressure that Israel
exerts on Washington to uh pursue
policies that suit Israel um a lot of
people called you anti-semitic for that
and a lot of people will call you
anti-semitic for your arguments now how
do you respond to that do you think
that's
hysterical I think Freddy you can Define
anti-semitic any way you want and what's
happened here is we have reached a point
where anybody who critic sizes Israel in
a serious way is described as an
anti-semite uh I have a number of
friends who are
Jewish uh who are very Jewish and who
are anti-zionists they don't believe in
the Zionist Enterprise they're basically
internationalists at heart according to
most Defenders of Israel they are
anti-semites I think it's ludicrous to
call them anti-semites they're not
anti-semites you can argue that they're
misguided and you can argue that someone
like me is unfair in criticizing Israel
that I'm too harsh in my criticism I
don't think that's true but you can make
that argument but labeling me an
anti-semite or labeling someone who's an
anti-zionist and is as an anti-semite is
I think stretching the definition of
anti-semitism to the point where it
becomes almost meaningless I mean I do
believe there is real anti-Semitism in
the world and I condemn it I think it's
absolutely horrible I think what
happened in Europe for centuries is
disgraceful uh so I'm all in favor of
condemning anti-Semitism as long as it
has some reasonable definition but when
anti-Semitism is stretched to the point
where people like me uh are
criticized as uh you know one of the
world's lead for being one of the
world's leading anti-semites I I think
you know
we're we're making arguments that just
don't make sense or we're making charges
that just don't make sense do you think
that perhaps there is a bias uh among
the United Nations uh in the European
Union perhaps uh and certainly
International Aid agencies there's a
bias against Israel and there's a
tendency to uh push information to push
statistics uh that are then disputed do
you think there's a a weight of
international opinion that goes against
against Israel or would you say actually
it's the other way
around it all depends if you're talking
about the European Union you're talking
about Europe I mean I think the
Europeans basically back Israel uh to
the hilt uh I mean if you look at the
Germans and you look at Britain I mean
there's no evidence that uh the British
government or the British Elites or the
German government or the German Elites
are siding with the Palestinians against
Israel uh there's not a whole heck of a
lot of difference between how most
Europeans uh react to what's going on in
Gaza uh there's not much difference
between that and what the Americans are
doing the way I see it uh once you get
outside of Europe uh and the United
States to put it in slightly different
terms once you get outside of the West
there is no question that there is a
huge amount of criticism of Israel uh
for what it's doing to the Palestinians
and you know you talk about a
agencies it's not so much the aid
agencies it's the Human Rights group I
mean groups you want to remember that uh
Amnesty International Human Rights Watch
and Bellum which is the leading Human
Rights group inside of Israel itself
those three organizations which have
Stellar reputations from a human rights
perspective in my opinion have all
produced lengthy reports that describe
Israel as an aparti State and say that
is a crime against humanity uh and you
can rest assured that when all the dust
settles and these human rights
organizations uh look at what the
Israelis have done uh in Gaza they will
accuse the Israelis of war crimes
justifiably so so you know there is no
question that there is this body of
organizations in various countries
around the world that are highly
critical critical of Israel and there
are people in the west who are highly
critical of Israel and many of them by
the way Freddy are
Jewish very important to understand that
it's this is not a case where all Jews
are uh supporting what Israel is doing
in Gaza and in fact some of the most
significant resistance inside of the
United States uh to what Israel is doing
is coming from uh Jewish individuals and
Jewish organizations like uh Jewish
voice for peace and not in my name uh so
this is an actually quite complicated
situation uh and it's not like it's all
the world against Israel or everybody
but the United States against Israel it
it just doesn't look like that at all
when you begin to sort of Peel away the
layers of the
onion John M it's always a pleasure
talking to you um thank you very much
for coming on to spectator TV and thank
you for all your appearances this year
uh I wish you a very happy Christmas and
uh I'm sure everyone will hope for a
more peaceful New
[Music]
Year